anxiety is at an all-time high kids are
depressed and anxious and nobody knows
why there's a crisis an epidemic of
depression men are designed to provide
and care for our families if you don't
do that you're always going to be
working against that grain their
position is so fundamentally confused
and absurd that when that's your
starting point you can't possibly say
anything true did Elon ever reach out to
you everything about you as a person is
decided in that moment Matt Walsh thank
you so much for coming on the iced
coffee hour obviously now you're tent at
the daily wire but I didn't realize you
used to be a professional dancer dude
you're really good at dancing I was
actually really surprised I found this
video of you here check that out um this
is on Twitter of you Dan playing yeah
just go and click play I can't believe
this got out yeah see you see my moves
there they're really good yeah you have
great hips hip
gyration the the footwork is incredible
on that yeah you know I put a lot of
hours it's just me
uh in my bedroom by myself dancing and
looking in a mirror so that that guy
does look you know the thing is people
are always telling me Oh this guy looks
exactly like you and I look at him it's
like he just has a beard so not everyone
that has a beard looks like me it's not
just the beard it's the glasses it's the
hair it's the facial structure it's the
I mean there's a lot of similarities the
strut the swag all that yeah the hip
gations especially should maybe Do
genetics testing and see if maybe you
guys are related to some maybe I am
related to every guy with a beard in
yeah so to start this off one quick
question it's a simple question okay
yeah what is a
woman that is still on the journey no my
Journey's over so it's a adult human
female I finally have learned is what a
woman is yeah and what is a a female
well a female is uh there's few
different ways you could Define female
but I prefer to say that a female is uh
that member of the human species who by
her nature can become pregnant and you
have to specify by her nature because of
course if you say well female is the
person who can get pregnant of course
then you're going to get the the whole
well what if you have someone who's uh
who's infertile or or or or whatever
that doesn't you know we know that that
by your nature a female could get
pregnant but that doesn't mean that
every single female can because there
there's disease there's genetic
deformity that sort of thing that can
get in the way I was surprised how many
views what has a woman got on Twitter
and I was sitting there refreshing and
watching The View just go up and up and
up and and I think it hit 100 million
views in how many hours after posting
this it was like the the weekend or it
was like yeah it Wass I think it was a
couple of days maybe we got the 100
million and then I think we made it up
to 180 million I want to say uh and you
guys took it off right yeah originally
we were going to put it up I think for
the original plan was for 24 hours and
then the response was so huge that we
decided why would we take it down we
just kept it up and we got up to around
180 million views and then Elon Musk
retweeted it didn't he said it was a
must he he pinned the he pinned it which
we did not we had no idea he was going
to do that obviously we're very grateful
um but there was a whole you know there
was a whole uh uh controversy before
that with Twitter initially trying to
shut our screening of the film down
before Elon Musk came in because the
thing is you know Elon came into Twitter
uh X I guess I'll never call it X I
always call it Twitter but he came in
and he started cleaning that house but
of course you know the company is still
for a long time is a fundamentally
left-wing company so I think there's
this kind of push and pull and when we
first announced our plan to put the the
the movie on Twitter you know there were
people at Twitter who uh tried to step
in and sabotage it until Elon Musk how
do you know that how do you know that
people within Twitter were trying to
shut it down what were they doing
specifically well because there was a
whole I mean there was a whole thing
behind the scenes we we we had this
whole plan set up to officially uh uh
Premiere the film on Twitter and it was
going to have its own special page which
you can do on Twitter now and uh that
would give it like prior prity in news
feeds and stuff and and and you know
make it accessible to more people we had
the whole plan set up everything was
good to go and then at the last minute
um we were informed that the decision
was made by some people at Twitter that
uh the film is hate speech and so we'd
still be allowed to have it on the
platform but it'd be impossible to share
it would be very difficult for people to
see it so basically like you can have it
Bas right exactly um so we don't know
who who at Twitter made that decision
and what exactly was going on behind the
scenes we don't know know uh but we know
that once Elon personally got involved
you know all that went away so did Elon
ever reach out to you uh I've
communicated with them a little bit a
little bit behind not like phone calls
or anything but just messaging that's
crazy yeah it is it is it's does that
how does that feel just on a personal
level talking to Elon Musk I guess what
do they call impostor syndrome where you
you you know you sort of feel like
you're in a position and and you don't
deserve to be there and and you're
trying to figure out yourself so it's a
little bit of that I feel a little bit
of the impostor syndrome when I'm
talking to somebody like Elon musk like
why is this guy talking to me what does
he talk to you about not much I mean
it's just like it's just it a little bit
messaging back and forth I think around
this the what is woman thing and then uh
and then a little bit here and there
since then but not not much at all
that's crazy I was surprised just how
detailed that documentary was and how
long it must have taken you to film it
because as a Creator myself I know how
much work goes into that behind the
scenes and the amount of time and
dedication that you must have spent on
that as with your entire team how long
was that from start to finish probably
about a year I want say a little bit
less than a year um and yeah it's it's
tough to make a movie like that because
it's you know it's not like a scripted
feature where you can and obviously
there's a lot of challenges there with a
movie like that but you you know it's
not like you have a script and you have
actors um I mean this kind of movie we
we knew what we wanted who we wanted to
talk to the issue we wanted to explore
but you really have no idea what's going
to happen when you get on the ground and
you're in the room with some of these
people um or you know my favorite
sequence in that film is when we went to
Africa
and um that's the sort of thing where we
had the idea we thought it'd be really
interesting to go to Africa and talk to
a traditional tribe about these issues
and just kind of get their like far
Outsider perspective but we obviously
had no idea what they would actually say
or how that would go and and what were
their what was their response to the
whole like question of transgenderism
and what is a woman uh they were flumix
I mean they weren't FL well they
actually originally they were flumix by
the question what is a woman not because
they don't know the answer but because
it's such a obvious answer that they
figured we must be asking something else
like at first when I I think when I
first asked what is a woman um and we're
going through a translator which is also
interesting we wanted to see how that
worked too like how do these
questions filter through a translator
into their language um and there were
some there were some issues with that
originally which we anticipated but when
we first asked it they gave some kind of
answer about um the duties and
responsibilities of men versus women
because they figured that's what I was
asking because in their mind Minds it's
like there's no way he's actually asking
literally what is a woman because nobody
everyone knows that and so I had ask a
few more times before they understood
that oh no this guy is like actually
confused about that question
specifically and when they were talking
about roles and what were some of those
things that they said there in terms of
what what a man's role was what a
woman's role was was there anything to
you that was surprising no it wasn't
surprising at all it was you know they
have an idea about the roles of men and
women that and that that they share with
almost every society that's ever existed
on Earth um aside from ours and in their
in their notion of things you know the
man provides for the family the woman
has children and stays home with the
children takes care of the house the man
goes out and provides for the family and
for them that's you know hunting that's
livestock you know it's not like they're
not going to a 9et to-5 job outside of
the the modern Western World you talk to
almost anybody and they're going to give
an answer like that now they understand
that if a man doesn't go out and provide
for his family like he's still a man
literally speaking but he hasn't
fulfilled his responsibility as a man
and when you were talking to people on
the other side of the token which you
did a lot throughout this what is a
woman documentary was there anything
that they said that you thought was like
a valid argument or maybe that surprised
you because you obviously went in with
certain expectations of what they would
say did you hear anything where you're
kind of like oh that kind of makes a
little bit of sense I understand that no
never honestly there wasn't so it was
there was no like aha moment it was just
certainly not an aha moment I'm I'm
trying to think if anyone said for on
that side of it if there was anyone who
said anything that I even thought was
vaguely interesting or legitimate and
the answer is no because because their
their position is so um fundamentally
confused and absurd that when that's
your starting point you can't possibly
say anything true like when your when
your starting point is that men can have
babies and that's the universe you're
living in it's it's a universe so
divorced from reality that whatever you
whatever come whatever grows from that
root is going to also be untrue and so
uh what I what we encountered that side
was just a whole like mess of confusion
basically so who holds these beliefs
because I was at the University of
California Santa Barbara so like a
public school in California and a lot of
people I found obviously like mostly
liberal students uh in college but I
didn't see many people with that level
of like extremism that like men can like
have babies and stuff like that I think
uh yeah that's always that's a
fascinating question too about um how
many of the people that pretend to
believe this actually believe it you
know when when we were making the film
we kind of there's sort of two groups of
people we talk to and one were the
experts you know the doctors and and
professors and that sort of thing Dr
Kamar can biological men become pregnant
and give birth so men can have
pregnancies especially transmen um and
then we also just talked to normal
people on the street what we found is
that the normal people on the street
often times were repeating kind of a
version of what we heard from the
experts but if you dug a little bit
deeper it became obvious to me that they
don't really believe what they're saying
um and you know this was also a couple
years ago when we were making the movie
I think that even now that might be
different I think now if I went out and
we did it again and I talked to normal
people on the street about this issue I
think we'd have more people willing to
say oh that all that is nonsense you
know if I were to ask like what if a man
identifies as a woman should he be
allowed to go into women's restroom when
we were filming this two years ago we
found very few normal folks on the
street who were willing to say well no
obviously the man can't go in the
women's restroom but they also hadn't
fully bought into the idea that he
should they're just kind of like they
were just uncomfortable talking about it
and because they knew that it was a
taboo yeah and I've I've often wondered
if we were to go back and do that same
man on the street sort of thing now
would we find many more people who are
willing to say well no of course he
can't I think a great poll to do for
your for just like a standard video of
yours to just go out and do it and I I
think we would I mean I think that that
and the polls and surveys on this issue
kind of bear that out so how did you get
started with the daily wire obviously
now you have a massive platform where
like millions of people listen to you
obviously the documentary was viewed by
hundreds of millions of people what led
to this position that you're in right
now I know you did a video reacting to
your first ever podcast which was it
itough start some our first podcast yeah
our first podcast was was not good we'll
throw up some b-roll it right here I'll
throw up some Boll your first podcast
I'm sorry but were you in a a building
at least were you in some kind of We
Were we were in a studio your mic didn't
work mine did so I converted a bedroom
in the house to a set and that's what it
was and then we and then we used our
dining room table for the next year and
then now we still we went back to the
converted bedroom well humble beginnings
still but at least you were in a bill
you were in some sort of stable
structure that stays in one place I
started in in media I suppose when I was
20 years old um I'm 37 now so this 17
years ago initially I was in uh I I was
in radio and I um left home at the age
of 20 and I went to this small Market
rock radio station in Delaware it was
like Market 300 something or other um
and uh that was the only in to media
that I could find at the time uh so I
worked initially overnights just like
introducing rock songs and uh that's
what I did I was there for about at that
station for five years and then I got
into kind of conservative talk radio for
a few years this is also when the radio
industry was also collapsing you know at
the same time so I got I got kind of got
in at like the tail end I think
satellite radio is beginning to take
satellite radio was starting to to come
on uh when I first started in radio of
course the internet existed but social
media you know was not what it is today
Myspace uh yeah this is back in the my
space I don't even think YouTube existed
yet but anyway I eventually I got out of
of radio and I was just a blogger for a
while I had my own blog but it blew up
like quickly too yeah it actually it
actually did surprisingly uh quickly I
started I think I started the the blog
in like early of early 2012 good time
for a Blog yeah that was that was in the
Heyday the other thing is that back then
and then it kind of blew up in that
summer I had a couple like viral posts
that I wrote and what were the viral
posts the first one that went really
okay the first one that went really
viral was actually very early it was in
the first few weeks when I started the
blog and it was a uh
uh my wife and sister-in-law forced me
to go see lay miserab the musical yeah
and I wrote a review of lay Mizer Rob
and how much I hated it and uh for some
reason it it went for me by my standards
at the time it went really really viral
I think I had like 500,000 views on that
on that blog post and um and then it
kind of you know it dipped back down and
I didn't capture any of that reader show
I didn't really know how to so I had all
these people reading this one people
just coming from Google because I'd
imagine your blog ranked in and if
people are typing in that your blog is
probably coming up and that's how
sharing it that one ended up on some
like message boards for musical fans or
fans of musicals or something you got a
lot of hate yeah there a lot of that but
there also people that were that were
commiserating and that said I also hate
this fil you know this this play film
why is it so highly contended why why
did you dislike it so much well I think
I didn't I'm not a musical guy first of
all and I didn't understand when I went
to go see it that they sing through the
entire movie it's like the the entire
thing is sung so I thought it was one of
those musicals where you have normal
scenes and then they break out in song
randomly which is annoying enough but
this one they sang the entire thing and
I was just and my wife didn't warn me
about that and you've got like Russell
Crow a trigger warning yeah I needed a
trigger warning I didn't get one so I
was I was shocked and appalled um but
what made you go home and write about
this and what did
you think about you writing about this
did she like she like my my husband yeah
she thought it was hilarious I think I
was I was kind of venting about it and
so and my my Lamentations of misery just
caught on for some reason but but the
problem is that I got all these viewer
these readers I didn't know how to
capture them because they were there for
a a movie review and I thought should I
just write movie reviews now is that
what people want but I don't want to you
know I'm not much of a movie critic so
they all kind of went away and then uh
it was several months later that I
started to catch on you know more
consistently and how would you catch on
in what way how did you find your Niche
I started writing about uh I think the
first one that really went viral that I
was able to sort of capture was um it
was Miley Cyrus performing at the VMAs
this really like gratuitous
objectionable performance back in 2013 I
think it was was with was it with Robin
Thick I think oh was that the one where
she was uh like grinding no no she was
grinding up behind him he bent over and
I think she got behind him I think it
was one of those right yeah you remember
this in great detail yeah still watches
it all the time I didn't see uh it was
it was something something like that and
so it was a big kind of like cultural
controversy at the time or he grinded on
her it was
one remember someone grinded on the
there was a lot I think there was
grinding going on all over the stage
with lots of different people um so but
I kind of wrote about that from the
perspective of sort of parent and so
that's the thing for a while I was kind
of when I started writing about uh
things relating to Parenting and family
and kids and how do you protect your
kids in this Fallen world of ours in
this degenerate culture
um that's what uh that's what seemed to
resonate with people which which is is
good because that's what I actually care
about and so I yeah I did that I did
that for uh for a few years I ended up
working at The Blaze for about three
years just as a writer and then uh I
think it was in 2018 that I got the job
at the daily wire was the blog making
money it was yeah it was it was uh by my
standards it was pretty incredible like
a lot of money by my cuz I you if
remember I was in local radio of course
how much were you making in local radio
radio my first gig in local radio I
remember specifically was $177,000 a
year how do you how do you survive off
that barely like $117,000 a year is well
it did quickly so it was $17,000 a year
I quickly got a raise to 19,000 because
I found out because they hired some
other guy a few weeks later and he was
bragging about making $119,000 a year
and then I'm like why are we not making
the same the same position yeah exact
same position and so they said all right
you you got us and so they gave me the
raise to 19,000 but even 19,000 is like
very hard to survive on so it was a lot
of um and that's what I made pretty much
until I got married I mean I was that's
it's a year into marriage I was still
making about that and so it was a lot of
uh you know uh gas station hot dogs for
for dinner and Foot Longs what was the
blog doing financially the first real
check I got from the blog was like
$4,000 that's fantastic for for a month
oh wow yeah and was that just it was the
ads that you had on the side like Google
ads yeah and yeah I I remember that very
well because that was more that was it
was a double like double my salary yeah
so it was the most money I'd actually
seen at one time 4,000 bucks and uh and
it was possible to do that at the time
because you know you could the way I
built that up was was through Facebook
and social media and back then you could
build up a readership on something like
Facebook which is pretty much what I
exclusively used at the time and if you
had 8,000 followers on Facebook they
would all see you know you could access
all of them and so if you had 8,000
followers it means that 8,000 people
were actually getting access to you were
popping up in their news feeds and
everything um but then quickly all that
started to change and you know now it's
like you could have a Facebook following
of two million people but only whatever
0.5% of them will even see post but guys
before we go into that are you ready to
make 2024 for your year of success if
you've been dreaming of starting your
own business there's no better time than
right now to turn that dream into a
reality with her sponsor Shopify Shopify
is the global e-commerce platform that's
already helped transform millions of
businesses worldwide Shopify has an
endless list of Integrations thirdparty
apps and flexible templates to make your
store exactly how you want it and if
that's not enough of a reason Shopify
also have the internet's best converting
checkout to turn browsers into buyers
and it's 36% better on average than
their leading competitors Shopify even
10% of all e-commerce in the United
States and that includes Brands like
Alberts rothis and Brooklyn and in over
175 countries and also just from
personal experience I've been using
Shopify for the last few years for my
coffee company bankroll coffee and I
absolutely love them there was no other
e-commerce platform that I'd even
consider using because Shopify is that
good plus they have an award-winning
support team to help you every single
step of the way so sign up for Shopify
is $1 per month trial period at
shopify.com and that's all lowercase
shopify.com
/ic so grow your business no matter what
stage you're in with a $1 trial period
shopify.com with the link Down Below in
the description thank you so much and
now let's get back to the podcast why
get into radio to begin with because you
think that there's a lot of careers out
there why pick something that pays 17 to
19 Grand a year I'd always wanted to be
in
media and uh for reasons that are are
even hard to explain like why would
anybody want to do this I don't I don't
know exactly but people but I did and um
I tried normal jobs I I from probably
about the age of 16 to 20 I I had I
don't know 17 or 18 different jobs and
what was the weirdest nothing really
weird it was just a lot of like
delivering pizzas which I actually
enjoyed pizza delivery was was great
there was a lot of freedom in that you
make who did you work for Domino's Pizza
Domino's I like Domino's of every job
outside of what I do now that was my
favorite job and uh this was before GPS
you actually had to learn I did Map
Quest this is before Map Quest before
Map Quest so we had we actually had a at
Domino's we had a big map uh in the
store and when you got the order you had
to go on the map and look and remember
are you serious shocking to the kids
today but yeah and then but then
eventually you actually
learn where you live and you learn how
to get around this might sounds stupid
what happens if you get lost do you have
a cell phone that you could call I
someone and just say like hey I'm I'm
lost about these two streets where do I
go well if you know if you at least V
know the area like you actually
understand where you live then you have
certain even if you get a little bit
lost you know where you can go back to
to get back the problem is now that
we're so dependent on um GPS that we
never learned like I've lived here in
Nashville I've lived in Nashville for
two years and I still I'm ashamed to say
hardly know how to get around because I
always use the GPS is that is that a bad
thing to not know how to get around
right yeah he relying on GPS I think
it's a bad thing yeah really for me it's
I'm able to put on the GPS and mentally
I could be somewhere else not having to
pay attention to directions but I can
think in my mind of different ideas or
different instead of like what street is
this am I going to pass it it it takes
away my mental energy on navigating when
I could rely on something like GPS yeah
but I think that's a bad thing because
that's it's exact that's exactly the
problem you're not really inhabiting
what you're doing you're not you're not
you're not inhabiting the current moment
your thought is always somewhere else in
the future or or anywhere or you're
looking at your phone and doing
something else you know you're on
Twitter or something while you're
driving not that I would ever do that I
think it's good to actually like okay
I'm driving this is what I'm doing I'm
going from here to there you're you you
are aware of the present moment you're
inhabiting it and going from point A to
point B like we don't do that anymore I
know it's a common but self-driving is
going to take that away eventually where
you're just going to be in a thing you
plug in the address you could sit back
and do whatever do what do whatever you
want to you could work could listen to
podcasts but we're we're slowly we're
taking away all of the things that for
for people to do so that increasing
there's like nothing left to actually do
anymore and so we're making life more
convenient oh you don't have to do that
anymore well then once there's nothing
left not once we get to the point where
we don't have to do anything then then
there's nothing to do then like life is
well then I think people go on to higher
and better things is that is that what
you see in society right now people
going on to higher and better things I'd
say overall if we look at this year
versus 40 years ago I'd say overall yes
I think in terms of efficiency and
productivity we're able to do a lot more
do a lot more what uh I would say with
technology advancements in society I
think there's a lot of a lot of
progression that we've seen well maybe
technologically but do do you see
progression do you think
people are better do you think people
are uh happier with all this I have no
idea I'm happier this year than I was 10
years ago you might be but I but I think
I think that the the trends would show
that most people we hear it all the time
that anxiety is at an alltime High kids
are depressed and anxious and nobody
knows why it's you know there's a crisis
an epidemic of depression
so it seems to me like people are so
yeah we got all these technological
advancements but I don't think that it's
making people happier it's not making
our lives better and
ultimately everything that we do should
be making our lives better if it's
not then it's a bad thing sure and and
also and it makes us vulnerable so uh
which to me is a secondary concern but
the fact that none of us know how to get
around our own neighborhoods well if
that technology ever goes away you know
if your interet internet goes down power
gets attacked whatever like we're we're
stuck we don't know what to do I mean I
I was uh driving to
work I don't know why I'm admitting this
I was driving to work a few weeks ago
and I couldn't get the GPS to work for
some reason and I you're just stuck I
like had a mini I I kind of panicked a
little bit
because because like I'm not sure if I
exactly know how to get where I'm going
but the Panic was more I can't call
someone and admit that I'm lost on my
way to work so that's emasculating to
the extreme so I figured out I fig Bud's
dominance how did you figure it out I
had to I had to tap into my subconscious
because I'm only I'm only ever like
subconsciously aware of where I'm
driving because I have the GPS so I had
I had to a lot of mental effort but I
did figure it out but it's pathetic like
how can I be a grown
man it doesn't even know how to exactly
how to get to my own job because I
always had the GPS so The Dominoes gave
you good training of navigation I I
tapped into that Domino's experience
so you think that there's Merit to being
aware and living consciously and present
rather than potentially your brain
solving other issues in the future or
thinking about past events and stuff
like that yeah yeah and I also think
that it's uh it's very generous to
assume
that that we're all up in our heads
solving problems I I don't think that's
what happens I think we're just kind of
killing time I mean it's it's a cliche
sort of thing to complain about but it
is we've all like you know know um I was
where was I I was somewhere recently
maybe the dentist or something and we're
waiting in
line and you look around in a waiting
room for example and you look around and
like everybody is just looking at their
phone you know and and it used to be
that in that situation maybe you have a
magazine or something most people are
you're just like sitting there you're
you're in the waiting room this is what
you're doing and you are doing
that um but we don't know how to like be
somewhere now we have to always you know
what's so funny I I see this picture
floating on the internet all the time
and it shows a group and they're all on
their phone and then it shows a picture
of the 1920s but everyone was just
reading the newspaper and it shows that
like human nature still hasn't changed
that people are still paying attention
to one thing in front of them whether
that be the newspaper or in this time is
the phone where you could get the
newspaper you know digitally or you
could be on social media but it's the
same sort of thing where people are in
their own world yeah but I think that
with each advancement it becomes it
becomes more absorbing and more uh and
it dominates your time even more I mean
the newspaper at least is a finite thing
and you can read the whole newspaper and
then that's it you're done with the
newspaper uh but the phone is made to be
infinite infinite scrolling you just it
never stops and you never look away from
it so yeah people might have been
distracted by newspapers but nobody 100
years ago yeah was walking around
reading the newspaper 10 hours a day and
now you know the average time spent on
the phone I think for Gen Z something
like 10 hours a day 10 12 hours a day
how do you spend your time on the phone
uh well it's hard for me because this is
what I do for a living so I have to you
know I have a daily podcast
so I have to always be looking for
Content you know that's like my life is
trying to find content and anytime
something happens in the
world you know it's not just a thing
happening it's like oh this is content I
have to what's my angle what am I going
to say about it so that's mostly what
I'm doing on the Internet is like
feeding I got to feed the content Mill
this this is what we do for a living MH
but outside of that I'm doing what a lot
of other people doing which is like I
I'll catch myself just last night I was
I caught
myself it's almost like 45 minutes had
evaporated and I just spent that 45
minutes just like I don't even know what
I Wasing I can't even tell you what I
looked at it was just like scrolling
scrolling scroll what app was it it was
Twitter Twitter Twitter's dangerous I
find Twitter extra dangerous because
it's just like fear-mongering and
negativity and just really pissy people
there's a lot of that and and and and
recently I've noticed a lot more just
these video like really violence oh the
gore videos yeah I mean has that hit
your algorithm oh yeah um it's so weird
I jack is telling brought this up to him
like yesterday I was like dude I'm
getting scarred even Instagram reals
because Instagram used to be very
sensitive to that stuff but you can go
and there's not even any warning or
anything it's like you just swipe and
then it's just
like you don't get any of that nothing
he curates his algorithm oh yeah I do I
purposely say if I'm not interested in
something very early on I say I'm not
interested mine is so curated to just
what I want to see which is Reef
aquariums watches pretty much oh you're
into aquariums yeah well let's talk
about that all right um I'm I'm a big
aquar well I'm not a big I want to be a
big aquarium guy um yeah I I have that
same uh that same issue and uh it is it
is very like if you say that it's
scarring or traumatic people will call
you sensitive like no it's not but I I
don't think no it is actually it would
be to me if I saw to to to just be gone
about your day and then oh there's
someone dying like there's someone being
shot to death right and that's
sandwiched in between a cat video and
somebody complaining about Trump or
something it's like so the fact that
you're witnessing it and then also the
context of it being just content that
you scroll past is uh it's very
unnatural and unhuman I do think that
there's Merit in knowing uh and being
aware of like the evils that exist like
for example with this whole recent thing
and Ben putting on this very graphic
content on his daily podcast like I can
see the angle that he's trying to show
to people just like contemplate your own
mortality know that evil exist and do
your best to fight it so I think it's
important to like be aware of it but as
far as like seeing it and being exposed
to it on a daily basis I don't think is
necessarily healthy yeah it depends on
the context that's why I said the
context is important so uh yeah I think
there could be a for something like that
but most of these videos that you see on
Twitter or whatever it's not they're not
raising awareness about some evil thing
that happened it's just it's to gawk at
and and uh that's entirely different
from you need to be aware of this evil
that exists out there I want to know
about your own ideals and principles a
question I love asking people to
understand who they are is what
principles and ideals did you have at
one point in your life and maybe one of
them specifically had a one 0 flip like
maybe you thought this thing about
raising kids you thought this principle
about who you are how other people works
so the the way reality is and it just
flipped 180 or has that never really
happened to you which also is a valid
answer uh I can't say that any
fundamental principle has flipped so
I've always been I was raised uh in a
conservative Catholic Family and uh
that's who I am that's what I am today
so for the most part the um fundamental
principles have remained the same same
but my views on various issues have
certainly changed I you know and some of
this is just growing growing up I think
back in my early 20s I was much more
libertarian in fact I would have there
was a time when I would have identified
as libertarian um I don't
anymore there's individual issues like
capital punishment I used to be against
capital
punishment um now I'm very much for it
and you mentioned parenting I mean
there's all kinds of I don't think it's
any principle of parenting that's
changed but gradually
evolved or or when you start doing it
like you have your ideas about
before you have kids you have all kinds
of ideas about how you think it will go
or or or how you uh think that you you
know how you think it should go and then
once you're um once you're in it it
could be entirely different I've also
before I had kids and I would see these
parents who in my mind are too lenient
and they just want to be friends with
their kids and I I never understood that
like how how can you be this way with
your kid you know like lay down the law
right uh you're not a friend I used to I
used to say that before I had kids like
you're not supposed to be a kid's friend
uh you're the
parent and now that I have kids first of
all yeah I think it's a bad you
shouldn't be too lenient you you need to
have you need to Discipline Your Child
make sure child's discipline but I do
understand why parents can air in that
direction because I I couldn't have
understood this before I had kids but
now I understand like punishing your kid
is hard I don't like doing it I really
don't like doing it I don't like coming
home from work and
one of the kids did something bad and I
have to deal with it and I really don't
like it not because I don't want to be
bothered but just because uh it's a it's
like an unpleasant thing I don't want to
have an unpleasant interaction with my
with my kid uh so I I understood I
understand that in a way that I didn't
before I had kids and I also uh have
changed my view about being friends with
your kid I've realized that you
absolutely should be your child's friend
you shouldn't be just their friend but
what is a friend a friend is someone who
has a close bond with you someone who
understands you someone you can confide
in um someone you like being around so
definitely as a parent not only should
you be your child's friend but you but
you should try to be their best friend
um where they which simply means they
like being around you and they will tell
you things and they will confide in you
and they trust you it's just you're
their friend but you're not their peer I
think is the distinction that I I missed
before I had not they equal how do you
determine what's an appropriate
punishment let's just say one of your
children acts up how do you make sure
you don't go too far or too soft on an
issue first of all I'm not I'm not
overly dogmatic on some of these things
some people are very dogmatic about
punishments they say uh never spank or
don't do timeouts or don't you know I
think there could be a place for all
different kinds of uh punishments but
the main thing is that most people
say which is true which is that
uh you you don't you shouldn't be angry
while you are administering the whatever
the punishment is you shouldn't be angry
while you're ministering it now in
reality dayto day you're G to get ticked
off at your kids it's G to happen like
it happens to everybody you always want
to P in fact I had this situation with
my with my uh my six now he just turned
seven my seven-year-old son this morning
where he did something very out of line
and I was very uh and his and you know
my wife sent him to me and and I was
initially pretty ticked off when I heard
about it but I told him okay you need to
stand there in the corner until I'm
ready to talk to you you and then I you
know I left the
room so I could calm down a second so I
could actually approach this like an
adult and then I went and I talked to
him and I administered the uh I I gave
him what the consequences were going to
be for the action but when you go in and
you're just like pissed off then then
then you're then you're just taking your
anger out on your kid um and that's not
parenting you know that's just that's
just you venting so it's leading by
example right and you're also
so many of the problems you have with
kids is that they're not able to control
their emotions and they're not able to
react rationally rationally and in in
you know to to to frustration that's
like 95% of the problems you have with
kids is based around that but if you are
demonstrating a similar inability to
control your
emotions uh a similar inability to react
the right way to frustration then you
know how can you expect anything better
from them you can't expect your kid
to be a better person than you are and
you can't expect them
to um demonstrate a capacity that you
yourself have do not have do you give
them access to the internet no at all
not at all no well uh they don't have
phones they don't have any kind of
unfettered internet access at all
um you know we will I'll put on a
YouTube video with you know I'll watch
my son my 10-year-old son likes to watch
YouTube videos of people in the woods
like building shelters sure and uh which
I also enjoy so we'll sit and we'll
watch that so you know he's accessed the
internet in that
sense but no there's never a time when
I'd be okay with them just sitting off
in a corner somewhere accessing the
internet at what age do you think that
is acceptable I don't think there's ever
a time when they're actually kids when I
would be okay with them having
unfettered internet access just because
I know where that leads you know I know
I know what happens
um eventually though they do you I don't
I also don't want to be in a position
where they turn
18 and they've
never they don't know anything about
tech they've have no uh they have no uh
familiarity with
it wouldn't want to put them in that
position either because then you're also
worried about them finally getting the
phone and just going nuts like because
it you know so I think eventually you
have to slowly kind of
introduce that stuff in a in a very
controlled setting which is what we will
do what are you most concerned about if
they have access to the internet of
course one of the primary concerns is
the pornography and the gratuitous
objectionable content that's all over
the place like what we just talked about
even stuff like that you can go on
Twitter and just see someone get shot in
the head you know as your scrolling pass
um so there's that there's the sexual
content you know there's the fact that
according to some studies the average
age of first pornography exposure for
kids is like eight now I mean it's
crazy and I don't think we have
any concept of just How Deeply that is
affecting and changing like whole
generations of human beings who their
first introduction to human sexuality as
a concept is internet pornography it's
just I think we're whistling past the
graveyard a little bit on on what that
means for the human race to have to to
eventually you know be a civilization
where everybody's in that boat that's
that was everyone's first
introduction um so I'm very worried
about that for my kids that's probably
the main thing but also just I want them
to
uh have a childhood I want them to be
able to entertain themselves and use
their imagination and go and do the
things that I did when I was a kid
anyone who's an older Millennial and a
and and older than that we all we love
talking about our childhoods of you know
when I was a kid I ran out Barefoot and
in the woods and my parents said be be
back for dinner but that's what we did
but do you think you could do that today
because I hear a lot of people saying
well yeah it was safer you know 40 years
ago and kids could go and do that and
they come back on when the street lights
go you know come on yeah could you
recreate that today I think a version of
it depends on where you live yeah uh if
I lived in an unsafe neighborhood or the
city I I certainly wouldn't do that but
um if you live like in an neighborhood
that I lived in when I growing up I just
lived in a normal middle class
neighborhood and that's the kind of
childhood we had we left in the morning
and we came back at at night and um if
the neighborhood is safe there's no
reason why you can't do that at a
certain age you wouldn't send your
5-year-old out like that but at a
certain age um I think you can and even
if you're not comfortable with that you
still uh you know I I don't send my kids
out totally out of my sight for hours at
a time but they're still out in the yard
playing they play games they
they like to color and draw and that's
how they spend their time and I want
them to have that but before we get into
that guys the daily wear is obviously a
massive operation I mean you can just
see from these shots and the audio
quality alone that this equipment has
got to be incredibly expensive but
thankfully though you don't have to
spend a whole bunch of money to get
started in fact we started with the bare
minimum and our sponsor streamyard is
there to help streamyard is a recording
and live streaming platform that allows
you to create highquality content right
from your browser with just the click of
a button from there they also allow you
to stream throughout multiple platforms
all at the same time from LinkedIn to
YouTube to Instagram Facebook Twitter
Tik Tok and more and if you're not on
every single platform you're absolutely
missing out so if you guys want to
create highquality content right from
your browser with just the click of a
button and also help support this
channel it would mean so much if you
tried out streamyard with a free package
guys it's completely free with the link
Down Below in the description again it's
absolutely free to start creating high
quality content today with a link Down
Below in the description enjoy thank you
so much and now let's get back to the
podcast and what about managing your
relationship how did you meet your wife
so I met my wife uh on e-harmony
actually yeah she doesn't like me
admitting that public year was this 2009
okay yeah what what attract like you
would be against dating apps right no
I'm not I'm not at all I'm not against
well first of all back then a dating
site is probably different from what a
dating app is is now um and these were
dating sites that were designed for like
okay I'm interested in someone I want to
meet someone who's a Ser a more serious
person and looking for an actual
relationship Harmony had that reputation
of being more like marriage focused like
you're there to find somebody versus I
think Tinder is like I'll find somebody
tonight right and I don't think Tinder
existed back then I'm pretty sure uh
dating apps in general I don't think you
know those were those were still in the
future of the time so I think yeah if
you're on one of these hookup apps where
this is what people use it for to hookup
then yeah you're not going to have
success probably finding someone who's
serious about having a
relationship but it is true that just
even I know from my own experience that
towards the beginning of the 2010s it
already started to feel like if you want
to actually meet someone how else do you
do it it's a lot of the normal communal
spaces don't exist anymore um or it's
not what it used to be so how many dates
did you go on with other people before
you went on that first date with your
now wife uh my memory is she was the
first one I met on the side
um I don't know we talked on the phone
for several weeks uh and then we before
we went our first
date and I proposed to her six months uh
later what Drew you to her profile
initially do you remember what the first
message was I take it you messaged her
first now I get in trouble I don't
remember all these details as well as I
should uh you know I think uh yeah
that's probably correct I don't remember
what the exact first messages were I
wish I did but what was it about her
profile that you saw was it was it a
picture first was it something she wrote
that you really liked or was it just
like here's our best recommendation this
is who we think that you might get along
well I mean she's beautiful so that as a
you know in reality that's going to be
the first thing you notice so that is
the first thing I noticed but it also
was clear to me that she's just a
serious person no I say serious I don't
mean like she can't laugh she's very
she's also very uh you know joyful but
just she's looking for she's not not a
an overgrown child like she's an adult
but you can't I don't think you can tell
a lot based on a profile anyway you have
to actually talk to someone and then we
went on our our uh first date and you
know I kind of
knew two hours into the conversation
that I that I wanted to marry her I
don't two hours into the conversation
was there something specific that she
said that you were just like yep we we
related on on a on our like our
fundamental values kind of
aligned and uh I thought she was
just she had a very warm affectionate
personality beautiful woman
um I could talk to her about you know we
talked about interesting things it
wasn't yeah we had the small talk like
had to get past that but we were talking
about whatever politics and religion and
all the the things they tell you you're
not supposed to talk about on the first
date we talked about all that stuff and
um and so it's like yeah of course I
want to marry her what else am I like am
I going to wait for some this is it this
is what you want right um which is what
I'm always like preaching to young men
that I'm not saying that I didn't
propose to her on the spot I waited six
months but like you have to know what
you're looking for and then once you
found that person it's like okay you you
found them you you win yeah you won that
part of the game but how did you know
what you were looking for did you date
prior to then and you're like I don't
like this I don't like this and then
when you met your wife you're like this
is this fits what I want I dat I mean I
met her when I was 24 so of course of
course I dated before that um and I
didn't have any experience that was like
oh man that's the worst thing ever I me
I was plenty of nice people it just
didn't we didn't really what it was is
is it's that our our fundamental like
principles and values aligning I didn't
I never quite had that uh to the extent
that I did with with my wife um and you
know they say the whole thing about
Opposites Attract and I think that's
true and my wife is like very much the
opposite of me in a lot of ways
uh P but that's all personality wise and
that's fine that's good I think you want
that but your values like the things you
want in life the things that motivate
you you know I think those have to line
up and if they don't maybe you can make
it work but you that's a huge hurdle you
got to get over early in the
relationship and it's never going to go
away if you don't have that fundamental
alignment the way that we did it just
seems like like if that is arguably the
most important decision that you're
going to make in your entire life is who
you're spending the rest of your life
with
don't you think that a longer period of
time getting to know them also making
sure that you have all of these stats
and data points of what you really do
like and what you don't like even years
of experiencing that plenty of options
plenty of choices than picking the the
winning Contender would be the I don't
know like let's say data driven most
effective decision no because I don't
think it is a data driven it's this is
not this is why I don't like when people
use the word partner to talk about their
spouses uh because it sounds like a
business that's what you say about your
business associate they your partner and
um I don't say that about my wife she's
not my business partner this wasn't a
business merger these are two human
beings who have uh come together in what
I believe to be a sacred Sacrament you
know your souls are are becoming
intertwined in a real true and mystical
way I think in the sacrament of marriage
and so it's just it's something that is
uh it's it's so far beyond a business
merger I don't like to think of it that
way and
it's also this is why I don't think
people say well you got to move in
together and so you can figure out all
the different quirks the person has why
like yes they're going to have quirks
they're going to do stuff that annoys
you you know you're gonna have pet
peeves like you yes so you don't need to
move in to find out about find that out
about somebody I can tell you right now
you'll have all that and if you're going
to allow that to be a deal breaker well
then you'll just be alone forever you'll
never marry anybody what matters is the
is the fundamental alignment
like do your values
align are you attracted to each other
that of course really matters and uh if
you have both of those things that's
what you need and the other thing is
that once you get married it's not
like it doesn't matter how long you
date
uh once the marriage happens it's sort
of like you're you're starting at square
one anyway you still have to have your
first day of marriage no matter what uh
so you could be you could be dating
someone for 10 years or 10 minutes
like once you get married now you're
married and now a new phase of the
relationship has
started
uh and you you have you have to walk
into that first phase no matter what no
matter how much experience you have you
know I also think
that part of it is this idea people have
that uh you know you're looking for your
soulmate you're looking for the one you
know I hate that phrase of oh she's the
one people ask me that sometimes how'd
you know she was the one well she wasn't
the one I mean it's not like there's one
person out
there of the eight billion people
there's just one out there who was
designed spe specially for you and it's
written in the stars and you have to
find that one person uh that's not the
way it works uh you don't find the one
person you find a person who you line up
with in this way and then they become
the
one when you say I do when you get
married you know so it's like you get
married married not because this person
is the one they become the one at when
you marry them and that that's what
makes the marriage vows so powerful is
that uh is that you are choosing each
other this is not Destiny aligning this
was not written in the stars is you you
are two people who were like lost out in
the cosmos and you have chosen each
other and created something new together
if your wife does not look good in a
dress do you tell her yes yeah I'll be
honest about that no I think she looks
good in almost everything so uh but yeah
I've never found that to be I don't know
people see that as a hard question but I
think you got to be honest with your
with your spouse and uh and she'll tell
me like if I look ridiculous wearing
something she will but you won't be
offended like you know what I mean like
I I think there's a difference in
reactions between women and men when
they you know yeah I mean you want to be
look obviously you want to be gentle
about it you know because you look like
a hideous like like a hideous hag in
that thing get out of it um but if
you're asked and yeah I mean okay what
if you're not asked if I'm not you see
something you're like hey that does not
look good do you say something it I mean
it would have to be like egregious you'd
have to be wearing something that is
embarrassing for me to offer up my
opinion but I I don't think I've ever
seen her wear something like that but if
she asks me and she's like hey what do
you think of
this I don't really like
it she doesn't get offended by that
maybe she's unique as as a woman in that
way but she doesn't get offended by that
sure the way that you explain
everything makes it seem like it's all
just so simple you very matter of fact
you know nonchalant about these really I
would say like Broad and but also like
dense questions you know has it have you
always kind of felt like you had I don't
know like like things were simple to you
or do you think life is very complicated
uh I think a lot of these questions are
simpler than we make them out to be I
think there's a difference between
simple
like something can
be simple and yet difficult but doesn't
make it
complicated so I think a lot so
something for example like finding the
right person to marry I think it's
simple what you have to do is a simple
thing doesn't make it easy it could be
difficult uh losing
weight it people want to make it very
complicated it's not complicated it's
actually very very simple just eat less
and exercise more it's extremely simple
that's all that needs to be said about
it but it's not easy so I think we
conflate these these things we we think
that
um we we have we have trouble
distinguishing between simple and hard
and and and complicated like these are
all different categories now we were
talking to Michael about gender roles in
a marriage do you feel like a man could
be happy in a marriage assuming a
traditionally female role let's say a
stay-at-home husband or a husband who
you know does the housework cooks and
the wife goes out and she makes the
money first of all I wouldn't even say
that cooking I wouldn't I wouldn't
even categorize cooking as part of the
as as like a feminine Duty
necessarily
um but generally speaking like that that
total R reversal that you're talking
about I'm not going to say look I'm sure
there are people out there that have
done that and will attest that they are
happy and I'm sure they exist uh I'm not
denying that those people exist but I do
think that they're going to be an
exception to the rule and the general
rule is that a
man will most likely not be happy unless
he is fulfilling his basic Duty as a man
the duty that like we talked in the
beginning that almost all human
civilizations have
um recognized which is that you need to
provide for your family um and I think
that what happens is that if a man is
not doing that if he's the stay-at-home
husband the wife is out being the
breadwinner
uh it might be fine for a time but the
man's going to start to feel useless
he's going to start to feel
emasculated and the woman is going to
struggle to respect her husband because
she's going to start to see him that way
too she's going to start to see to
herself like what do I need you for I'm
doing everything and whether they admit
that out loud and they'll say is a
different question but I think that's
that is what ends up happening and and
once when the man doesn't respect
himself or struggles to and then the
woman doesn't respect the man you now
now your marriage is on life support now
you are that's turn that's that could be
a terminal case um it's a that's a very
very dangerous place to
be um and that's why the man you know
the respect for the man in a marriage
has to be it's a very important thing
that has to be nourished and cherished
yeah it also seems like a bit of a hot
button issue if the wife or the woman
makes more money than the man
and it seems like a lot of men are
either insecure about that or a lot of
women say I'd prefer the man make more
money yeah and and I think that is how
most people feel um again I'm sure there
are exceptions I'm sure that uh someone
will happily will say in the comments
that oh my wife is you know the CEO of
whatever and we're happy
um and I'm not and I'm not going to deny
that there are individual cases like
that but you you are kind of working
against the grain of human wiring like
we are wired a certain way so men are we
are designed to provide and care for our
families and because we're designed that
way we want that's what we want to do we
want to do what we are designed to do
that's that's happiness is do is doing
what you're meant to do is is happiness
and uh I I think
uh if you don't do that you're always
going to be working against that graan
so for the average viewer that's 18 to
35 years old old most likely a man if
they find themselves waking up they're
unhappy on a day-to-day basis or they
feel unfulfilled what recommendations
would you give to them to feel better
don't think stop thinking about your
feelings so much you know I think that's
part of the problem when people we you
know we live in a culture that's very
focused on
feelings and so we're always thinking
about how we feel and how we feel about
how we feel and it becomes this kind of
like infinite regress where we're just
stuck in our own minds like looking back
into ourselves and then we get into
this uh into this kind of Rhythm where
we think
well I can't do anything else I can't go
out into the world and be successful and
productive unless I get my I gotta get
myself right right you hear this people
people say this stuff all the time I
gotta get myself right I got to work on
myself and then once I got that figured
out then I can go out and do all these
things um I don't think that happiness
works that way I think that happiness is
a
byproduct of doing what you're supposed
to do in life and so it's more it's it's
not a it's not an end to itself
exactly so I think
it's the happiest moments I've had in my
life is when I'm just doing something
else and then I stop and I look and I go
oh I'm really happy right
now okay and then I get back to what I'm
doing it's like you you kind of notice
it but you don't dwell in it you don't
you don't try to sit there and and like
bask oh so happy you just get back you
get back to what you're doing and you
and you are happy and you're doing this
and it's great you don't even think
about happiness but if you try to if you
try to sit there on the couch and
conjure happiness like like a genie out
of a lamp yeah it it it will never
happen and if it does it'll be so
fleeting but what if you reflect and you
say I am really unhappy doing this one
thing when do you take that into
account yeah well that's why happiness
and action are are are intertwined and
so it could be possible that you're
doing there's plenty of things you can
do that will cause you to be unhappy and
um and
now your unhappiness that that that
could be a a sign to you that you should
pursue something else um or it could be
that you're unhappy doing this
thing and the issue is not that you need
to stop doing it it's that you need to
look at it differently you'll hear from
some parents sometimes will will say I'm
just miserably happy I'm miserably
unhappy being a parent every once in a
while it's like every month there's
another article written by some cat lady
in the New York Times Washington Post
talking about how terrible it is to be a
mother that sort of thing now in that
case obviously or I hope it's obvious
that the answer is not to stop being a
parent um you can't stop being a parent
anyway you are a parent you'll always be
a
parent so if you're unhappy as a parent
then it's it's almost certainly that
you're just looking at the wrong way
you're focusing on the wrong things it
does seem like because I do read a lot
of Reddit and I see these posts and it's
it asks how many parents had kids that
regret having kids and there seems to be
and I don't know if this is just a
selection bias of just reading the
people that that post but it does seem
to be that there are a lot of people out
there who have kids who just don't want
to be a parent don't like being a parent
and if they could take it back they
would they love their kids but in
hindsight they they you know wouldn't
have had the children how common do you
think that actually is I hope it's not
very common it does happen I think it's
probably more common today than it used
to be I do think there's a selection
byas on Reddit you know there's a
certain type of person
there what do it say about me I mean
look uh especially a certain type of
person that would post on Reddit about
their personal about their personal
lives regardless like so there's
selection
bias
um I I also don't think it's true I I
will say that if you feel that way about
being a parent you don't love your kid
so they can say that it's funny they
always throw that in there I hate being
a parent I don't want to be around this
little brat I wish he didn't exist oh
but I love him it's like then what is
love if that's what what is hate mean if
that's if that's love um no you don't
you don't love your kid actually and
that's exactly the problem actually is
is that uh is that love is is a is a
giving of the self it's a
self-sacrificing loving is uh Thomas
Quin said that love to love is to will
the good of the other um which just
basically means you want what's best for
someone and you want to help them get
what's best for them in life
um that's the job of a parent that's the
whole job right
there and and there's real joy in that
but I think these parents that are
miserable they've never they've never
even like attempted to do that job they
because they they they've never stopped
thinking about themselves for long
enough to think about their child so
they're just focused on the wrong
they're focused on themselves and and as
as a parent there's all these little
moments and no one does it perfectly I
don't certainly but there's all these
little moments that
happen and there's a real there's a
there's a fork in the road kind of
psychological thing here
where okay I can choose to look at this
situation this way and be really unhappy
about it and annoyed or I could choose
to look at it this way and I could find
great joy and as a parent you have these
little moments all the time throughout
the day so like um there a recent
example for me waking up in the morning
it's like a Saturday morning and I think
my wife had to go out for something and
so I was it was just me I have six kids
the six kids and they're all like
rambunctious and they need things and
you know everything and we got to do
breakfast and it's like this whole thing
and it's Saturday morning long long week
at work I you know and and so for a
moment there I was I was like miserable
I'm miserable and pissed off because
it's Saturday morning and everybody
needs me and my wife's not there because
she had to go out and I got all these
kids coming after me and uh I'm just
pissed off and miserable because you
know I just wish that I could lay in bed
and not be
bothered um cuz I had chosen to look at
the situation that way but then I
stopped myself and I said wait you know
okay I could choose to whine about this
and look at it that way or I could
choose to to to to to see it as wow this
is incredible I have this house full of
life and love and these beautiful young
kids are full of energy and uh think
about all the things that we can do
today and have fun and you know I can
see it that way and it doesn't always
work this way but in that moment I was
able to just like okay I'm going to
choose to see it that way and then I was
happy and I think for a lot of parents
they get into the habit of always seeing
it in the way that's going to bring them
unhappiness they always focus on the
things that will make them unhappy and
then they can't get they just get stuck
in that pattern do do you think people
need to have kids to be fulfilled I
think I think you have to be a
parent to be fulfilled but that doesn't
always take on the traditional kind of
biological sense so I think every man is
called has a paternal calling every
every woman has a maternal calling for
most of us that's going to be the
traditional like have kids and be a
mother or a father
um not everybody though and and there
are people who are called to a different
form of fatherhood a different form of
motherhood it might be charity it might
be Mission work it might be the
religious life it might be something
like that you know and you're not you're
not a parent in the in the and of course
there's adoption as well obviously but
you're still you're still taking on this
maternal or paternal role of caring for
someone else uh so no matter what you
cannot find happiness without living a
life where you are you know in service
to someone else and caring for other
people and the problem is that people
try to find happiness in service of
themselves only and in my career and my
own Financial advancement and all that
and U you're not going to find true
fulfillment that way that's for sure do
you think some people are just too
selfish though to have children that
maybe they're better off just not having
kids I certainly think there are a lot
of very selfish people and if you are
very selfish that you'll be a Terri
terrible parent but I I I don't want to
let them off the hook by say Well
they're they're selfish so because it
that's a it's a choice to be that way
they don't have to be that way it's not
like they it's not a birth defect so yes
I mean there there are selfish people
who in that state should not have kids
but my answer to them is not don't have
kids it's stop being a selfish
bastard um and then have kids you know
uh that that would be my answer to them
that's interesting it reminds me of what
horos was saying about patience but with
selfishness in mind you are a selfless
person if you're naturally a self
selfish person but you just choose to be
selfless like you are who you act as you
are your actions your behavior not
necessarily maybe what your brain is
thinking at a given moment so you act
patient even though you're super
impatient you're a patient person fake
it till you make it yeah I think it's
one of the one of the great uh wisdoms
in yeah so we have just a couple more
topics to hit on I know we're kind of
getting close on time um but you uh you
you didn't well I don't know if you
starred but you were in the the movie
lady Ballers I saw you in the trailer
you by the way make a gorgeous woman
well thank you uh but that is also see
that's that's the claim based on that
one little clip in the trailer is I must
be playing a trans in fact there's been
media reports that I'm playing a trans
saw that woman or a I've also heard that
I'm playing a gay a gay man actually the
character surprisingly straight
heterosexual male just I got the wig and
I've got the uh whatever it is the uh
what is like the robe the Buddhist like
yog yoga
robe I don't know toga no it kind of
yeah but like an Asian version anyway um
I didn't absorb this character very well
apparently so uh that's the basically
it's the the character is the most
liberal character in the whole film is
who they decided they wanted me to play
someone who's designed to be the exact
opposite of me in every possible respect
but did you did they ask you if you
wanted to be maybe like a woman or
something like that cuz I feel like that
would be kind of funny considering the
nature of what is a woman did you like
veto that yeah there wasn't much
conversation I mean there are you know
in the film it's part of the joke of the
film is that there are there are all
kinds of characters who are you know uh
identifying as women in order to play in
women's sports that that role was never
really floated to me because probably
mainly because it would involve playing
sports so they figured I'm probably not
fit for that um so this is this is what
they uh they gave me you know I didn't
even I read the script of the film I
didn't know what character they want me
to play they wouldn't tell me until
after I read it and then and then I was
informed that well you know that one guy
like the most obnoxious guy that you
probably hate the most that's you I
heard by the way I don't know if you saw
but the the recent alien existence you
know object that was found I think it
was in Mexico discovered by the Mexican
Government basically proves alien
existence what were your thoughts about
that just on existence in generaly to me
yeah I'm uh you know my audience knows
I'm fully bought in on the alien stuff
maybe maybe to an extent where it's
become it may it maybe has become too
much a part of my brand that uh that you
know I don't know if I want to be known
primarily as the alien guy but um but I
am uh uh you know the Mexican thing you
could argue like they they had actual
alien specimens that they put on
display some people have argued that
they looked clearly like little dolls or
something paper mâché I mean paper mâché
makes no sense you know I don't know if
that particular thing was legitimate or
not but I am quite firm in my belief
that number one aliens that being
rational beings elsewhere they don't
live on earth they certainly exist in
the universe and I think there's pretty
good indication that they've been to
Earth what they've done here how many
times they've visited I don't know but
there's enough going on that I think
that becomes a
rational theory in my mind why is it
rational to believe that life exists
outside of our planet to me the number
one reason is simply the size of the
universe it's this it's it's how big the
universe is and how many planets we know
are in it and we know that there are
trillions and trillions of planets in
the universe in the known universe
hundreds you know 100 billion galaxies
in the known universe 100 million stars
or so in each Galaxy you know which
which leads to trillions of planets so
uh I think that it's just sort of absurd
to like we don't know one way or another
right we don't know but if you had to
guess just intuitively right if you had
to guess is there life on other planets
or are we literally the only planet out
of trillions that has life on it I think
it's ridiculous to Guess that we're the
only ones the analogy that I use if
you're lost at sea and you wash up on
some Island somewhere and you know know
you don't know anything about the island
and but it's very very big you know and
uh you look and all you could see is the
beach and you look around you don't see
any life but this is all you've seen
it's just the beach this little this
little portion of the beach would it be
rational to assume based on looking at
what you can see of the beach that the
whole island is empty except for you no
I mean you would assume there's probably
something living here MH um based on how
big it is you know and I think that I
would say something similar about the
Universe I we can't even conceptualize
how large a trillion is you know no you
can't like a trillion people forget how
much bigger that is than a billion a
million or even just like one like it's
just
R counting seconds I think between a
billion and a trillion or even a million
to a billion is just absurd I'll put the
numbers right here you guys can see yeah
yeah when you get to counting to a
billion how many like decades that takes
versus a million is wild and the size I
mean just think about the the closest
star to us is like four light years away
and that's our that's our next door
neighbor that's like in UN in Galactic
terms that's like as close as you and I
are um and that's four light years
away which is trillions yeah which is 20
some trillion
miles
um with current technology it would take
like thousands of years to get there and
that's the closest start you in in just
uh our galaxy mhm and then when you
think about hundreds of of millions of
galaxies it's just it's absurd I want to
ask what is something that you think the
left is doing right and what is
something the right is doing that you
disagree with well in the first part so
what's the left doing
right I think on the on their
fundamental views they're wrong about
everything but strategically they
they've obviously look I mean they've
obviously
uh won the culture and we talk about the
culture War which I believe is a real
thing but the war is it's not like
two equal armies meeting on the
battlefield in a pitch battle this is
guerilla you know on the right this is a
sort of cultural Guerilla Warfare that
we're engaged in because we are a
conquered uh country culturally how do
you think did that well through through
the institutions you know they they they
took over very slowly but surely all of
the major institutions in this country
that
uh that run everything so they took over
Academia and the media and um and uh uh
Corporate America government the
bureaucracy you know but why were they
able to do that when the right wasn't
able to what was it about those
ideologies that made them so pervasive I
think there's a lot that goes into it
one one is that you know Academia for
for a very long time is always kind of
skewed left and school system so that
was a kind of a good starting point for
them because if you can take
over uh if you can capture
[Music]
Academia well well now you are in charge
of shaping the minds of each new crop of
Americans that comes through they they
until recently anyway they've been very
effective even when you look at like
Hollywood they've been very effective at
um spreading their ideas through
entertainment in ways where you don't
really notice where you don't notice it
so they've been very good at spreading
their ideas in ways that the person who
is ingesting those ideas hardly notices
now recently they've gotten very bad at
that so they're now they're very on the
nose you know with the woke Hollywood
films and everything and uh and they're
suffering because of it you it's why
Disney this whole year has not had a
billion doll film uh when in 2019 they
had like six of them because they're so
on the nose hitting you over the head
with the wokeness people notice it now
and they're like I don't want to go to
the movies and be lectured to but you go
back to the '90s I mean
even you think people people long for
the old days of Disney back in the 90s
when they were putting out stuff like
Pocas well those movies were also I'm
not going to say they were woke to the
extent that modern Disney is but they
they were very left leaning Pocahontas
for example is like Native America the
bad guys are the white Europeans the
Native Americans are talking to trees
and singing and you know this this
perfect group of people that were
dominating by the white Europeans like
it's a very left-leaning version of
history but generally speaking they were
much more subtle about it
um and I think that that was more
effective for them yeah and then what
what is something the right is doing
wrong or that you disagree with in
recent history strategically the right
has done almost everything wrong maybe
one of the big ones I would point to is
just this issue of like how how do we
how do we use things like entertainment
um to spread our ideas and you know up
until recently and obviously the daily
wire we're we're trying to offer some
kind of corrective on this but
historically you know you had Hollywood
you had the music industry and then you
had the conservative version of all that
stuff and it's just on the nose hitting
you over the head oh we made a Christian
movie about Christian values you can
come and watch it well it's like unless
you already agree no one's going to
watch it because they because they
realize that this is a whole movie where
the movie itself the story is secondary
to the message and so if you don't care
about the message or don't agree with it
you're not going to watch it
um and I I think the right's getting a
little bit better in that regard but but
only ever so slowly let's say you're at
a Kroger okay just picking something up
you're moving back to your car and you
see me and I'm walking up to my car with
my cart mhm and I put the groceries in
the back of my car and I get in the car
and I drive off and I I don't return the
cart to the cart return what do you
do um I pull out a gun and I open fire
on you as you drive away uh
nice I'm not quite at that point yet um
I
look I would there's nothing I can do
because you you've already you've made
your choice um but I will I will judge
you for silently and my opinion of you
as a person will have forever been
decided you know what's interesting is I
do think although that's kind of like a
minor offense I do think that that's
indicative of some deeply rooted
character flaws kind like kind of like
being it's like going out to a
restaurant and being mean to a waiter
you know what I mean like that sure the
offens is it's just a casual thing and
the waiter's going to forget about it an
hour later and you're not going to think
about it whatever but it's indicative
it's like if you find yourself in that
situation you're being mean to someone
rude to someone for no reason other than
maybe like a power Dynamic it's like
okay reconsider maybe who you are as a
person because I'm sure that that's you
know it's being exercised in other
aspects of your life as well that maybe
aren't so obvious I think it depends on
where you leave the cart no return it to
the cart return the cart return some
sometimes the cart return's really far
away but it doesn't matter what if a
gust of wind hits what if it pushes
that's why you have to put the wheels
over the little parking curb that's how
far the parking I've been in many
grocery store parking lots in my life
they're not how far are we talking next
to the return to make it actually you
don't the travel across the Sahar desert
I don't know trying to play devil's
advocate here I'm just trying to say
there's a difference between leaving it
behind a car just like in the in the
wind versus like there's no difference
no difference you put that's where the
carts go and you you managed to obtain
the cart in the first place like you
managed to figure that out you were able
to walk somewhere and get the cart push
it all the way around the store it's
also an eyesore and then as soon as you
get out all of a sudden it's like I
can't I can't go another step I can't do
it you you what annoys me the most are
parents we try to use that as an excuse
I got these kids with me I can't what am
I supposed to
do what do you mean what do you do you
take the kids with you to the C Corral
or you leave them in the it's like you
can the kids to return it that was like
what my job was or you can you can leave
the kid in the
car and and walk 20 ft away like he's
not going to get kidnapped what do you
think's going to happen in that in those
20 ft so no I I agree that it's it's a
small thing but because it's small it
says a lot it's it's kind of
like you
know if if you
uh open your door and you hit someone's
car in the parking lot next to you and
scratch their door panel something like
that everything about you as a person is
decided in that moment if you don't
leave a note if you don't leave a note
if you just leave and if you if you
drive away say I'll let them do well
that's that's like even though it's
small it tells me everything I could
ever need to know about I don't think
that's a small issue yeah that's a big
issue I would say because that's like
directly onetoone affecting someone else
whereas you know you put it over a curb
and it would take a lot for that to
actually negatively impact someone's
life we had a buddy uh this was actually
just recent uh he parked and the lady
parked right next to him and her kid was
in the back seat and just kicked the
door open and so he walked around
because they were in the car as this
happen and said your kid just dented the
thing and they no that was already there
and then they lined it up perfectly to
show that like the paint on this is the
same as this no that was we didn't do
that just like offended at the fact that
didn't Su the kid did it oh and it was
on camera by the way was the resolve uh
he I think just got some cash because
they didn't want to go through insurance
he didn't want to go through insurance
it's very expensive to it's unfortunate
as you know if your kid does that you
had to take SP but it's your kid you got
to take her I I was walking on the the
street year a few years ago with my son
and um and he
just he randomly picked up a rock just
that he saw on the and as if he was like
skiing rocks at a on a stream he just
threw it and it happened to hit a car in
that that was parked and I'm like what
are you but of course she's he like four
years old she's like I don't know I
don't know why I did that and so I had
to and it left a scratch so it's like
man and so I had to wait there for
someone cuz I they' run into like a
takeout place so I just waited waited
there for them to come out and I had to
you know how'd you resolve that uh I
think I yeah I think I gave him some
money or something I said like whatever
they want to do it was like however you
want to resolve this you want to send my
kid to prison that's fine like whatever
you want to do we we we are we are in
your debt now you should make your kid
go and explain his thought process to
that person say I threw the roong yeah I
made I made him apologize okay but and I
I was already asking him like why did
you do that what did you think explain
to me the thought process of picking up
the Rock and throwing it what did you
think was going to happen buty old he
could be scarred and never want to throw
rocks ever again yeah well no he's he he
he's that that didn't happen to him he's
he's still throwing not of cars though
not of cars okay um are there any other
pet peeves I feel like you lamenting
about things is just so I for me it's
just so exciting it's just so fun well I
I don't I don't think they're pet peeves
though because I think that these are
pet peeves are like things that you
because of your own personal quirks find
annoying but that are not objectively
wrong that to me that's a pet peeve uhuh
um but the things that I'm talking about
are objectively wrong so I I don't have
any pet peeves you don't have any pet
peeves no because if I'm complaining
about it it's because it's wrong and you
shouldn't do it so it's not a pet peeve
so your pet peeves are based on reality
it's based on just a moral intuition
it's object objective morality yeah I
will I will not admit that any of them
are actually pet peeves because if I
admit that then I'm admitting that it's
just a I just I admit that I'm just a
whiny bastard which I know that there
are plenty of people who say Bobby but I
won't admit it I refuse to admit it so
got it okay well as we wrap up we have
one last ask of you which is could you
do word association for just a couple
words for us oh okay so first thing that
comes to mind when I say Matt
Walsh uh we're holding back you're
really curating this yeah cuz you want
me to just like say the first word yeah
first word that's say it again Matt
Walsh
me Michael
NOS
person I'm gonna make this as boring oh
no okay you give us like a little like
Association so it has to associate in
some capacity no because I can't I can't
open up the psychological door I can't
do it I got I gotta protect myself Ben
Shapiro uh wonderful
employer Brett Cooper a lovely person J
boring great boss all right
Biden son of a
okay all right thank you so much
Matt for your time apprciate it thank
you to the daily thank you the entire
production team once again you guys are
amazing and with that said you guys till
next time next
time